Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Die EU, das EU-Parlament hat eine EU-Sports Policy verabschiedet, die rein theoretisch zumindest sich auch bis auf den deutschen Fußballerinnen auswirken könnte. Darüber spreche ich mit Petra Kammerevert. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 191. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter und heute werden wir mal sportpolitisch. Ihr hört gleich ein Gespräch, das ich geführt habe mit Petra Kammerevert. Sie ist im EU-Parlament seit 2009, sie ist in der SPD, sie hat eine Stehplatzdauerkarte bei der Düsseldorfer EEG und ist Mitglied bei Fortuna Düsseldorf. Das ist vielleicht an diesem Punkt hier auch noch relevant. Und sie war vor allem mitbeteiligt bei der Vorstellung der neuen EU Sports Policy. Die wurde verabschiedet vom EU-Parlament und betrifft das ganz große Bild. Die Rolle von Sport, die er in unserer Gesellschaft spielen soll und welche Regeln da vielleicht auch notwendig sind, damit er diese Rolle erfüllen kann. Es ist ein sehr interessantes Papier, wurde nicht so viel darüber berichtet in den hiesigen Medien. Deswegen wollte ich es an dieser Stelle nochmal aufgreifen. Aber bevor ich jetzt alles nochmal erzähle, gerade eben ist das Gespräch mit ihr zusammengegangen. Ich würde sagen, ihr könnt es jetzt hier, wie immer natürlich ungeschnitten und am Stück hören. Das war mein Interview mit Petra Kammerevert. Frau Kammerevert, herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk. Schön, dass Sie sich Zeit nehmen. Ja, ich freue mich sehr, dass wir heute über Sportpolitik sprechen können. Denn das möchte ich vorausschicken. Das ist so ein bisschen meine, vielleicht auch naive Haltung. Ich glaube, wenn sich im Sport nochmal etwas verbessern soll dahingehend, dass wir gerechteren Wettbewerb bekommen und vielleicht auch eine Umverteilung, dann wird das, glaube ich, nur über EU-Politik und EU-Maßnahmen in den Sport hineingetragen werden. Bin ich da zu naiv oder teilen Sie diese Hoffnung?
Na, also diese Hoffnung kann man schon haben. Das Problem ist nur leider, dass wir im Moment im Bereich der Sportpolitik nicht so richtig viele Kompetenzen auf EU-Ebene haben, sondern dass, wie auch im Bereich der Kultur- und der Bildungspolitik, ein sogenannter subsidiärer Politikbereich ist. Das heißt, die Zuständigkeit liegt eindeutig bei den Mitgliedstaaten, sodass wir alles, was, ich sage mal, legislative Maßnahmen angeht, also dass man irgendwie versucht, irgendwas in ein Gesetz zu gießen, dass wir das im Moment so nicht dürfen. Und deshalb ist auch der Sportbericht, den wir jetzt als Parlament verabschiedet haben, erst mal ein Bericht, wo wir, ich sage mal, unsere Forderungen vor allen Dingen erst mal sowohl an die Sportverbände auf der einen Seite, weil die Sportverbände ja auch immer großen Wert darauf legen, dass sie, ich sage mal, in Eigenverantwortung ihren Sport organisieren, was ja auch im Prinzip völlig in Ordnung ist. Dass wir also die Forderungen an die Sportverbände adressieren, aber natürlich auch an die Mitgliedsstaaten, weil, wie gesagt, wir halt von den Kompetenzen her legislativ hier nicht tätig werden können, sondern nur unterstützend und koordinierend. Nichtsdestotrotz nehmen wir diese Aufgabe im Parlament sehr ernst und machen auch tatsächlich in jeder Legislaturperiode einen solchen Sportbericht, wo wir dann unsere entsprechenden Forderungen und Positionierungen auch formulieren. Und ich glaube, der Sportbericht, den wir jetzt verabschiedet haben, ist einer, der in vielen Bereichen auch sehr, sehr deutlich Forderungen an die Mitgliedstaaten, aber auch an die Sportverbände adressiert.
Auf die wollen wir gleich kommen. Aber das sind eben, wie sie richtig sagen, Forderungen. Nur für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das Wort vielleicht nicht parat haben. Subsidiarität, das ist eines der Prinzipien der EU. Das heißt, dass man Gesetzgebungsverfahren an den Landesregierungen nicht wegnimmt, um es mal so ganz banal zu formulieren.
So kann man das formulieren, ja.
Genau, und dann kommt jetzt aber einfach so ein frecher Ausschuss für Bildung und Kultur, Frau Kammerevert, in dem Sie eben Mitglied sind für die SPD im Europaparlament, schon seit 2009 und stellt dann durchaus einige Forderungen und kritisiert auch einiges im Sport. Was war denn der Anlass dafür, diesen Bericht jetzt zu veröffentlichen? Und wie sehr geht er vielleicht auch ein auf aktuelle Entwicklung? Denn ich habe, obwohl es ein Bericht zu Sport ist, habe ich schon viele Punkte gelesen, da kam es mir vor, als ob explizit über den Fußball gesprochen würde.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein bisschen auch den aktuellen Diskussionen geschuldet, die wir jetzt in den vergangenen halben Jahren, Stichwort Super League, geführt haben oder führen mussten. Insofern ist es natürlich ein sehr allgemeiner Sportbericht, aber natürlich wissen wir auch, dass der Fußball nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern in Europa insgesamt natürlich schon eine sehr, sehr große und wichtige Rolle spielt. Deshalb lässt es sich natürlich auch nicht vermeiden, dass man hier auf aktuelle Entwicklungen eingeht und da auch eine entsprechende Positionierung zu vorgeht. Aber letztendlich geht es in dem Bericht natürlich um alle Bereiche des Sports, vor allen Dingen natürlich seine Bedeutung für Bildung und Gesundheit. Und natürlich auch die Bedeutung des Profisports, aber natürlich auch des Vereinssports, des Amateursports, also des Sports, den man, ich sage mal nur, letztlich aus Spaß an der Freud betreibt. Und nicht, weil man damit Geld verdienen möchte. Also es wird schon die gesamte Bandbreite des Sports auch in dem Bericht abgedeckt. Und das, worauf wir uns halt im Wesentlichen beziehen, ist eine Definition und auch eine Stärkung des europäischen Sportmodells, was sich, ich sage mal, in einem Satz zusammenfassen lässt. Sport dient dem Allgemeinen wohl und nicht dem Wohl und dem Geldverdienen von wenigen.
Das, glaube ich, ist ja der springende Punkt. Denn nach dem, was ich bisher verstanden habe, ist es so, sobald das in Gesetze gegossen wäre, auch auf Landesebene, dass Sport eben einem höheren Zweck dient, als eben nur der gesundheitlichen individuellen Stärkung, sondern eine gesellschaftliche Funktion bekommt. Ab dann würden sich auch regulierende Maßnahmen rechtfertigen lassen, legitimieren lassen. Ist das letztlich das, worauf Sie im Großen dann abzielen?
Ja, wobei, also ich sage mal, wir wären natürlich schon auch froh und glücklich, wenn die Sportverbände selbst das Heft des Handelns ein Stück weit in die Hand nehmen würden, weil ich finde, Selbstorganisation und Selbstregulierung ist immer besser, weil daraus natürlich auch ein Stück weit eigene Überzeugung spricht, als wenn man mit dem gesetzlichen Hammer um die Ecke kommt. Gerade weil wir natürlich auch die Selbstorganisation und die Autonomie des Sports achten, wäre es uns natürlich lieber, die würden selber anfangen, ich sage mal, auch ihren eigenen Laden ein Stück weit zu reformieren. Das hat ja durchaus schon ein paar Ansätze gegeben, aber wir merken dann auch immer sehr schnell, dass diese Ansätze dann doch auch, ich sage mal, ein Stück stecken bleiben. Wenn ich da an das Financial Fair Play von der UEFA denke, wo ich sagen würde, es ist eigentlich eine prima Idee, das mal auch selbst zu regulieren, ein solches Financial Fair Play. Aber wir stellen dann eben halt auch sehr schnell fest, dass das dann über Ansätze auch letztlich nicht hinausgeht und leider dann auch, ich sage mal, beim Versuchen ein Stück weit stecken bleibt.
Ja, es ist halt auch schwierig, wenn die Verbände, bei denen vereint sich ja alles, Exekutive und Legislative im Sportrecht. Dass das nicht so gut funktioniert, hat man ja unter anderem an Financial Fair Play gesehen, wo dann die Sanktionen, da wo es dann wirklich knackig wird, dann irgendwie komischerweise dann doch nicht kam. Aber dann lassen sie uns mal inhaltlich reingehen. Also einer der Aspekte, der gefordert wird schon sehr früh, ist im Grunde das, mit dem wir eingestiegen sind, glaube ich. So ein bisschen nämlich erst mal die Zuständigkeit für den Sport, nicht nur des EU-Parlament, sondern es wird auch, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, gefordert, dass in der EU-Kommission eine Position geschaffen wird, auch um den Dialog überhaupt zu etablieren. Wo hakt es denn da aktuell?
Na ja, es gab auch immer wieder das Bekenntnis und auch den Ansatz, wir haben auch eine Generaldirektion in der Kommission, die tatsächlich auch für Sport mit zuständig ist. Aber es hat halt in den vergangenen Jahren nicht so wirklich gut funktioniert. Es hat immer wieder Ansätze, auch seitens der Kommission, gegeben. Aber wie gesagt, das ist dann auch über Ansätze letztendlich nicht herausgegangen. Es hat immer wieder Sportkonferenzen gegeben, wo man versucht hat, die Zuständigen auch, Verbände an den Tisch zu bekommen. Da hat es auch durchaus viele gute Ideen gegeben, die da entwickelt worden sind. Aber man ist dann, wie gesagt, auch über Ansätze nicht hinausgekommen. Deshalb haben wir jetzt in dem Bericht auch die Ernennung eines EU-Sportkoordinators gefordert und auch gefordert, dass Sport in die Bezeichnung der Portfolios eines Kommissaris mit aufgenommen wird, damit wir hier auch einen Kommissar haben, der sich dann federführend auch damit verantwortlich fühlt und den man auch verantwortlich machen kann. Also, den man dann auch zur Rechenschaft ziehen kann nach dem Motto, was hast du denn in dem Bereich gemacht? Weil ich glaube, das wäre schon mal ein wichtiger Ansatz. Wenn jemand mit einem Kommissar das auch eindeutig mit in seinen Aufgabenbereich hat, dann kann man ihn auch fragen und dann muss er auch dem Parlament beispielsweise Rechenschaft darüber ablegen, was er denn in dem Bereich getan hat. Und wie gesagt, wenn wir hier schon mal zu einer besseren Vernetzung und auch, ich sag mal, zu einem besseren Austausch auch von Best-Practice-Modellen kommen würden, wäre, glaube ich, auch schon eine ganze Menge gewonnen, ohne dass man sofort gesetzgeberisch tätig wird. Und es gibt da ja eine ganze Menge Bereiche, wo wir wissen, dass manches im Argen liegt. Da meine ich jetzt nicht nur die Sportorganisation. Also ein Bereich, der mir zum Beispiel ganz wichtig ist, ist die Frage dualer Ausbildung von jungen Sportlerinnen und Sportlern. Wir wissen, dass man Profisport eben halt nur eine gewisse Zeit lang in seinem Leben betreiben kann. Und wir stellen immer wieder fest, dass gerade junge Sportler, die so auf dem Weg zum Profi-Dasein sind, dann doch sehr auch sehr gerne ihre Ausbildung, sowohl die schulische, wie auch die berufliche Ausbildung, dann gerne auch mal vernachlässigen. Wir finden aber, dass hier auch die Vereine in einer besonderen Form auch in der Verantwortung sind, hiermit dafür Sorge zu tragen, dass diese jungen Menschen auch eine Ausbildung und eine gute Schule, einen guten Schulabschluss neben dem Sport haben und sie dafür auch die Möglichkeiten schaffen müssen. Wir wissen, dass es in Deutschland da schon eine ganze Reihe Modelle auch gibt und eine ganze Reihe Vereine, die das ordentlich machen, aber eben halt nicht fleckig flächendeckend und in Europa sieht das auch nicht viel besser aus. Und insofern glaube ich, ist das ein Bereich, wo man ein Stück weit auch dafür sensibilisieren muss und auch die Vereine nochmal ein Stück weit an ihrer Verantwortung packen muss, dass sie gerade für diese jungen Menschen, die ja teilweise auch noch minderjährig sind, auch wirklich ein hohes Maß an Verantwortung haben.
Jetzt ist er dann, aber das haben sie ja selber auch schon so eingeordnet, das wäre ja erstmal ein Verbessern des Dialogs, auch vielleicht ein Verbessern des Status Quos aktuell, welchen Zugriff hat denn die EU, die verschiedenen Institutionen der EU, Parlament haben wir jetzt schon so ein bisschen eingeordnet, jetzt hätten wir dann so eine Stelle in der Kommission, welchen Zugriff hat man auf die Verbände, denn wenn sie zum Beispiel fordern, dass es eine der Formulierungen, die auch am meisten auf sie natürlich erregt hat, sie fordern oder sie rufen dazu auf, da muss man ja sehr genau formulieren, ein Bekenntnis zu einem fairen Wettbewerb und gleichzeitig die Ablehnung von Wettbewerben, die sich den heimischen entziehen und in Konkurrenz dazutreten. Es geht um die Super League, ohne dass es dazu ausgesprochen wurde. Dann sind sie und ich, wir sind uns da einig, wahrscheinlich auch ganz viele Fußballfans. Und die Fußballverbände haben auch alle nach der Veröffentlichung gesagt, Mensch, tolle EU-Sports Policy, ganz herzlichen Dank. Aber welchen Zugriff haben sie denn eigentlich auf die Verbände?
Na ja, das ist, was ich eben schon ausgeführt habe, das ist natürlich ein bisschen das Problem, dass wir letztendlich keinen wirklichen Zugriff auf die Verbände haben. Aber ich meine, wir haben ja gerade bei der Super League gesehen, ich sag mal, öffentlicher Aufstreit, dass so viele Fans sich gewehrt haben, auf die Straße gegangen sind, gesagt haben, das wollen wir überhaupt nicht haben, hat dann zumindest im ersten Schritt mal dazu geführt, dass die ihre Pläne erstmal an Akta gelegt haben. Wir wissen, das ist nicht das Ende der Fahnenstange und da wird mit Sicherheit auch noch was kommen. Aber das ist so ein Punkt, ich glaube, wenn es über bestimmte Ideen auch eine öffentliche Debatte gibt, und da spielen, glaube ich, gerade die Fans eine ganz besondere Rolle, weil was wäre Fußball ohne Fans überhaupt nicht vorstellbar, weil Fußball lebt oder viele Sportarten leben eben halt auch von den Fans und von der Stimmung, die die im Stadion machen, dass das dann auch dazu führt, dass vielleicht dann auch die Vereine, die solche Ideen entwickeln, die sich an einem solchen Solidaritätsmodell, wie wir es mal formuliert haben, ja damit ein Stück weit auch entziehen, dann vielleicht doch also entweder zum Umdenken kommen, mal so einfach merken, gegen ihre Fans Dinge durchzusetzen, funktioniert halt auch nur gedingend und wenn die Fans nicht mehr da sind und keiner mehr da ist, der die teuren Rechte im Fernsehen dann auch angucken will, Wenn du sie alle sehen willst, dann funktioniert auch das ganze System nicht mehr. Alleine schon aus wirtschaftlichen Gesichtspunkten, dass die sich dann auch überlegen, das funktioniert nicht. Also insofern ist das, das was wir machen, hat natürlich sehr appellativen Charakter, Forderungscharakter, den Versuch, bestimmte Dinge auch in die öffentliche Debatte, auch in die sportpolitische Debatte zu holen, um dann sowohl bei den Mitgliedstaaten, die ja in dem einen oder anderen Bereich durchaus auch gesetzgeberisch tätig werden könnten, oder aber auch in die Verbände zu holen. Also da gibt es ja, ich meine, der Bericht hat ja nur eine ganze Menge Forderungen. Das fängt an bei den dualen Ausbildungen. Das ist das eine, das ist die Frage, die wir in Deutschland ja immer sehr hoch halten und ich glaube auch zu Recht sehr hoch halten, diese 50 plus 1 Regelung, die als Vorbild genannt wird.
Das fand ich sehr interessant.
Ja, die auch als Vorbild genannt wird und ich glaube das ist auch tatsächlich ein Vorbild, weil das natürlich nicht in Toto, aber dennoch ein Stück weit auch verhindern kann, dass große Investoren sich Vereine einverleiben und genau dieses Solidaritätsmodell, auch diese solidarische Finanzierung auch von Amateurbereichen, von Jugendarbeit, die ja gar nicht unbedingt dann zum Profi-Dasein führen muss, sondern einfach junge Menschen zum Sport zu bewegen mit den ganzen Vorteilen, die Sport natürlich auch bietet. Respekt, Toleranz, Fair Play, alles das, was da zusammen sind, ja alles Dinge, die man auch fürs normale Leben gut gebrauchen kann und die man da erlernen kann. Und insofern spielt Sport eine wichtige Integrationsrolle auch in Gesellschaft. Und das solidarisch zu finanzieren, auch über die Profi-Abteilungen, ich glaube, da ist die 50 plus 1 Regel tatsächlich eine, die zumindest in Ansätzen gewährleistet, dass das auch tatsächlich passiert. Wir wissen, dass es in Deutschland da eine Ausnahme von gibt, von dieser Regelung, dass, ich glaube, wer 20 Jahre lang als Sponsor einen Verein geführt hat, darf auch mehr als 50 Prozent haben. Da gibt es ja, glaube ich, im Moment gerade einen Klitsch zwischen dem Bundeskartellamt und dem DSG. Das Bundeskartellamt würde diese Ausnahmeregelung gerne kippen. Und ich glaube, das wäre gut, wenn sie kippen würde, weil das nochmal eine zusätzliche Absicherung eigentlich auch dieser 50 plus 1-Regel wäre. Man wird den Sport nicht vollständig entkommerzialisieren können, aber zumindest sicherstellt, dass dieses Solidarsystem, der Ausgleich zwischen kleinen und großen Vereinen, zwischen Profisport, Amateursport, Jugendarbeit, auch anderen Abteilungen in einem Verein, dass das weiterhin funktioniert. Und ich glaube, dafür ist die 50 plus 1-Regel tatsächlich eine wichtige Voraussetzung. Nicht alles, aber es ist eine wichtige Voraussetzung. Und deshalb haben wir das auch so explizit aufgenommen. Und ich fand das auch sehr gut, dass wir das so aufgenommen haben, weil wir sehen auch in vielen Ländern, guckt man nach Spanien oder auch nach Großbritannien, die sind jetzt nicht mehr bei uns dabei, aber Italien, dass das genau das Problem ist, woran insbesondere der Fußball natürlich, weil da so viel Geld verdient wird, der Fußball natürlich leidet und das setzt sich dann in den Vereinen nach unten fort.
Ja, da würde ich gleich noch mal drauf zurückkommen. Aber ganz generell würde mich interessieren, also wir haben jetzt in diesem Ausschuss insgesamt 29 Mitglieder. Die ganze Policy wurde dann auch vom EU-Parlament verabschiedet. Sie selbst waren, wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe, auch schon mal Vorsitzende dieses Ausschusses. Diesmal war es Domasz Frankowski, ein ehemaliger polnischer Fußball-Nationalspieler, hat auch unter anderem bei den Wolverhampton Wanderers gespielt. Wie kontrovers verläuft denn dann da so eine Debatte, wie zum Beispiel eben 50 plus 1? Es ist ja eigentlich ein ganz heißes Eisen, was hier so beiläufig als Punkt Nummer 23 von insgesamt über 80 drinsteht.
Erstaunlicherweise, ich war ja selber nicht in dem Berichterstatter-Team. Wir haben ja immer einen Berichterstatter und dann gibt es von jeder Fraktion einen sogenannten Schattenberichterstatter. Das war für die Sozialdemokraten, war das mein österreichischer Kollege Hannes Heide, mit dem ich auch ganz viele Erinnerungsanträge noch mal eingebracht habe, um die Forderungen da auch noch mal ein bisschen zu stärken und denen auch ein bisschen mehr Pfeffer zu geben. Aber mein Eindruck ist, dass die Verhandlungen im Parlament selber, im Ausschuss, in dem Berichterstatter-Team, dass das gar nicht so schwierig war, sondern dass sich da eigentlich alle im Wesentlichen einig waren, da muss man jetzt mal auch ein bisschen, ja auch gegenüber den Verbänden, ein bisschen deutlicher in der Sprache auch werden. Und ich glaube, dieses 50 plus 1 war jetzt gar nicht so der große Streitpunkt, sondern da haben eigentlich alle gesagt, das finden wir eigentlich eine gute Lösung, wie das in Deutschland geregelt wird. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es diese Regelung auch noch in anderen Ländern gibt, das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, also in dieser Form tatsächlich ist das ein deutscher, besonderer, eigener Weg. Das ist auch ganz interessant, weil auch 50 plus 1 steht unmittelbar über den Punkt ein Bekenntnis zu Menschenrechten und Demokratie bei der Wahl von Austragungsorten von Turnieren und der Wahl von Sponsoren. Da hatte man fast so den Eindruck, also mit dem FC Bayern hat man an der Stelle nicht geredet, aber es war... Nee, das muss ja auch nicht immer sein. Aber das führt uns ja eigentlich zu der entscheidenden Frage, an die wir jetzt immer mal wieder schon so angestoßen sind. Wir sprechen auf der einen Seite von Sport als etwas, das für Gesellschaften wichtig ist, das sowohl für das Individuum wichtig ist, als auch für das Kollektiv. Also Dinge wie Diskriminierung, Integration, Inklusion, Gleichberechtigung. Das sind alles ganz wichtige Punkte, die auch in dieser Sports Policy genannt werden. Das kann sehr explizit genannt werden. Das ist die eine Sicht auf den Sport und die andere Sicht auf den Sport ist, damit Geld zu verdienen. Also Sie haben vorhin die Formulierung verwendet, wir werden den Fußball nicht entkommerzialisieren. Ich glaube, da zucken manche instinktiv zusammen, wahrscheinlich nicht unter den Hörern und Hörern. Außer die DFL hört hier auch mit, zumindest manche Beteiligte der DFL. Es ist ja auch nichts Schlimmes und gehört ja auch zum Wachsen des Sports dazu, damit Geld zu verdienen. Aber wie kann man es denn schaffen, das in Einklang zu bringen? Auf der einen Seite ist es ein Wirtschaftszweig und muss auch nach wirtschaftlichen Regeln funktionieren dürfen. Auch das steht natürlich in der Policy drin, dass ja auch viele Arbeitsplätze damit geschafft werden und es im Grunde ein ökonomischer Sektor ist. Und auf der anderen Seite ist es aber eben nicht wie zum Beispiel die Autoindustrie, wo man sagt, naja, da gibt es eben den Mittel zum Zweck, nämlich man möchte ein Fortbewegungsmittel schaffen, sondern wir haben hier eigentlich ein höheres Gut, was komme oder nach ökonomischen Prinzipien funktioniert. Wie kann man das in Einklang bringen?
Na ja, ich glaube, in manchen Bereichen funktioniert das ja auch schon einigermaßen, das ein bisschen in Ausgleich zu bringen. Also wenn ich mir anschaue, dass beispielsweise die Fernsehgelder der DFB oder auch die DFL generieren über ihre Übertragungsrechte, dass da nicht der Spitzenverein, der kriegt natürlich das meiste, aber nicht the winner takes it all, sondern dass man da schon versucht, dass auch einigermaßen, ob das immer alles zutallgerecht ist, will ich jetzt mal dahingestellt lassen.
Da würde ihr eigener Verein fortun, oder du bist sie dort, die würde da widersprechen.
Dass man das versucht, einigermaßen zu verteilen und darüber auch einen gewissen Ausgleich zu schaffen. Ich glaube, da gibt es ja durchaus schon Ansätze. Ich glaube aber auch, dass man das noch besser machen könnte, als man das im Moment macht. Also insofern, glaube ich, muss man schon sehen, klar, auf der einen Seite Geld verdienen, ist ja auch erstmal nichts Böses und nichts Anrüchiges. Auf der anderen Seite dann aber gucken, wie man das Gesamtsystem sport, dann auch eben tatsächlich am Leben erhält. Wir brauchen die Nachwuchsarbeit in den Vereinen. Wir brauchen auch die Bereiche, die eben nicht auf den Profisport letztendlich ausgerichtet sind und dass man da versucht einen fairen Ausgleich zu finden und dass die Bereiche, die das Geld verdienen, die anderen Bereiche auch mitfinanzieren, weil sie auch die Basis für das sind, dass man am Ende tatsächlich Geld verdienen kann. Ich glaube, das muss sich noch ein Stückchen stärker durchsetzen und da muss das System vielleicht noch ein bisschen solidarischer und fairer werden.
Aber da würde Ihnen jetzt ja ein Vertreter oder eine Vertreterin, sagen wir realistisch ein Vertreter eines Profivereins, würde Ihnen sagen, naja, genau das machen wir doch schon. Wir haben ja XY-Nachwuchsleistungszentren. Wir zahlen XY an, auch Amateurverbände. Also es gibt ja diesen Ausgleich schon. Was würden Sie dem entgegnen?
Na ja, also ich würde dem auf jeden Fall entgegnen, dass nichts dagegen spricht, das noch ein bisschen fairer und noch ein bisschen solidarischer zu machen, als das bisher schon ist. Und außerdem haben wir sicherlich auch in Deutschland zwar die Situation, dass das alles, ich sage mal, einigermaßen ordentlich funktioniert mit dem Ausgleich. Das gilt aber natürlich leider nicht für alle europäischen Länder. Und wir haben diesen Bericht ja auch nicht spezifisch für Deutschland gemacht, sondern für alle 27 Mitgliedstaaten, wo wir wissen, dass das teilweise eben halt auch nicht so gut funktioniert wie in Deutschland. Ich denke, Deutschland ist da in vielen Bereichen durchaus auch ein positives Beispiel. 50 plus 1 haben wir schon gesagt, wo andere Länder sich vielleicht ein bisschen was von abgucken könnten. Aber auch in dem Bereich, glaube ich, läuft das in Deutschland ein Stückchen besser wie in anderen Mitgliedstaaten. Aber wie gesagt, wir machen das halt nicht nur für Deutschland, sondern eben für alle 27. Und ich glaube, da ist an der einen oder anderen Stelle tatsächlich auch noch ein bisschen Nachholbedarf. Und auch was die europäischen Verbände angeht, glaube ich, zum Beispiel die UEFA, auch da ist, glaube ich, der Reformbedarf durchaus vorhanden.
Ja, welche Rolle spielt es denn dabei, dass, wenn wir jetzt im Fußball bleiben, die weltweit größte Liga, die Premier League, jetzt seit dem Brexit nicht mehr auf EU-Ebene ansprechbar ist? Ist das ein Problem?
Ja, also ich sage mal, insgesamt ist das natürlich grundsätzlich ein Problem, dass die, oder finde ich das sehr bedauerlich, dass Großbritannien sich entschieden hat, nicht mehr Mitglied der Europäischen Union zu sein. Das macht es in vielen Bereichen natürlich nicht gerade einfacher. Aber also insofern hat natürlich auch im Sport der Ausstieg von Großbritannien nicht unbedingt geholfen, gerade weil die Premier League natürlich eine der ganz großen Ligen in Europa ist. Nichtsdestotrotz gehört ja die Premier League Großbritannien ja weiterhin zur UEFA. Und auch die UEFA hat man natürlich ein Stück weit den Zugriff und auch den Einfluss. Also insofern ist das, und ich sag mal, wenn man die anderen Länder in der UEFA, die ja auch weit über die Europäische Union hinausgeht, also die Türkei ist ja auch Mitglied in der UEFA, dann hat das natürlich schon eine Wirkung auch auf die Premier League und auf die Ligen in anderen Ländern, die eben nicht Mitglied in der Europäischen Union sind. Also ich sag mal, wenn wir es schaffen würden, die UEFA zu Reformen zu drängeln und vielleicht auch, ich sag mal, ihren guten Ansatz, Financial Fair Play, wo wir ja eben schon mal drüber gesprochen haben, vielleicht nochmal aufzugreifen und es besser zu machen, als sie das bisher gemacht haben, indem nämlich dann auch Strafzahlungen tatsächlich mal eingefordert werden, dann wäre auch UK ja wieder mit im Spiel und mit im Boot. Ich sag, das ist bedauerlich, aber da muss man jetzt gucken, wie man da irgendwie mit umgeht. Aber ich glaube, das ist jetzt kein Hinderungsgrund, weiterhin auch Gespräche mit der UEFA zu führen und weiterhin auf die UEFA einzuwirken, hier gewisse Reformprozesse auch anzustoßen und auch den Weg zu bringen.
Was mich zu den Reaktionen auf die Verabschiedung dieser EU-Sports-Politik bringt, es war Lobpreisung von allen Seiten. Die europäischen Fußball-Fanverbände haben gesagt, super, dass die Rolle von Fans anerkannt wird. Die DFL in Person von Christian Seifert hat gesagt, Mensch, finden wir alles super, haben wir Lust auf weitere Gespräche. Die UEFA, die FIFA haben gesagt, Mensch, das ist ja ein ganz toller Vorstoß, ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Mich macht das sehr misstrauisch. Wenn alle etwas toll finden, klingt das für mich so, als ob die auch alle das Gefühl haben, ja, wir loben das jetzt und dann wird es sowieso sich nie auswirken bei uns im Realen.
Ja, ich werde da auch immer ein bisschen misstrauisch, wenn alle es loben. Vor allen Dingen muss man ja immer gucken, die nehmen sich ja dann immer auch das raus, was ihnen gerade zu pass kommt. Also insofern muss man natürlich in den Gesprächen, die dann jetzt wahrscheinlich auch weiter folgen werden, denn wir sind ja auch durchaus im permanenten Dialog mit den Sportverbänden, dann auch darauf hinweisen, dass das hier keine Rosinenpickerei ist, sondern dass sie schon auch mit dem leben müssen, was wir ihnen vielleicht mit kritisch ins Stamm hochgeschrieben haben und dass wir nicht nur gerne das Lob entgegennehmen, sondern auch von ihnen erwarten, dass sie dann bestimmte Dinge auch schlicht und ergreifend mal machen und mal umsetzen, von dem, was wir da gefordert haben. Wie gesagt, Sie haben schon die Fans angesprochen. Wir haben ja, und das finde ich auch sehr schön, dass wir in dem Bericht auch nochmal sehr deutlich die Bedeutung der Fans betont haben und dass wir eigentlich auch erwarten, dass die Fans auch ein Stück weit stärker mit eingezogen werden in die Arbeit der Vereine. Viele Vereine machen das ja schon, aber eben auch nicht flächendeckend und vor allem nicht in den Verbänden. Und wenn das dann dazu führen würde, dass beispielsweise auch der DFB mal ein bisschen stärker mit den Fans kooperieren würde oder insbesondere auch die UEFA, dann wäre das sicherlich nicht von Schaden. Also da kann man jetzt nicht nur sagen, oh, das ist aber schön, dass das Europäische Parlament die 50-v-1-Regeln so gelobt hat und das fanden wir ja auch schon immer gut, sondern da muss man dann auch sagen, da müsst ihr auch bitte aber das auch mitnehmen, was wir euch dann sonst noch mit auf den Weg gegeben haben.
Ist das das, was Sie sich von Fans konkret jetzt wünschen würden, dass man weiter diese Themen so beackert? Also im Fußball haben wir da ja schon sehr aktive Fanszenen, aber wir reden ja auch noch über andere Sportarten und andere Länder. Ist es das, was Fans jetzt tun können und mitnehmen können aus dieser Policy?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also da kann ich, und ich meine, wir haben ja in Deutschland nun wirklich eine ganze Reihe von Fanorganisationen, die da auch sehr, sehr aktiv sind. Also da kann ich mir zu raten, das auch mitzunehmen und da auch immer wieder darauf zu verweisen, dass ja auch das Europäische Parlament die stärkere Einbeziehung von Fans auch gerade bei Entscheidungsfindungsprozessen hier eingefordert hat und begrüßen würde. Ich sag mal, wenn das den Fans auch ein bisschen Rückendeckung gibt, haben wir da sicherlich keine schlechte Formulierung bekommen.
Und gibt es auch einen Auftrag an die Medien, was da jetzt konkret passieren sollte, aus Ihrer Perspektive heraus natürlich?
Ja, die Rolle der Medien hat natürlich auch eine Rolle gespielt. Es gibt nicht nur in Deutschland, aber auch in anderen europäischen Ländern natürlich schon eine sehr große Fußballlastigkeit in der Berichterstattung. Zumindest wird das häufig so empfunden. Wenn man das mal ein bisschen genauer aufschlüsselt, ist zumindest in Deutschland der Wintersport, was Sende Minuten angeht, genauso stark vertreten, wie der Fußball ist. Aber gefühlt ist das ja immer so, als ob es eigentlich nur Fußball gäbe in Deutschland. Und dass wir da natürlich auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen haben, es gibt eben halt auch eine ganze Menge anderen Sport, es gibt Amateursport, es gibt auch im Fußball gibt es auch die Frauenliegen, es gibt den Frauenfußball, dass man hier ein größeres, ein etwas größeres Gleichgewicht auch in der Berichterstattung, was die über die Sportarten, was das angeht, und dass auch andere Sportarten ein Stück mehr Sichtbarkeit auch im Fernsehen bekommen. Das ist sicherlich eine Forderung, die das Parlament hier auch sehr deutlich mit auf den Weg gegeben hat.
Das ist mir auch direkt aufgefallen. Die einzelnen Forderungen beginnen immer mit verschiedenen Verben. Da gibt es welcomes, calls, also jeweils immer das EU-Parlament, Reiterates, Highlights.
Das ist die typische Art und Weise, wie wir in diesem Parlament Berichte schreiben. Ich fand das am Anfang auch sehr gewohnungsbedürftig.
Ich finde es eigentlich ganz interessant, weil genau das erste Wort gibt nämlich schon einen ganz guten Hinweis darauf, mit welcher Tonalität der ganze Absatz zu lesen ist. Und bei den Medien und der Berichterstattung über mehr Sportarten, sowie auch vor allem nicht nur junge Athleten, sondern auch vor allem über Frauen mehr zu berichten, da steht eines der wenigen Urges in diesem ganzen Policy. Das fand ich sehr treffend. Frau Kammerevert, dann bin ich sehr gespannt, wie da die nächsten Schritte sind. Und ich danke Ihnen sehr für Ihre Zeit, dass Sie uns das alles mal ein bisschen eingeführt haben. Ich wünsche Ihnen weiter viel Spaß bei allen Eishockeyspielen, die Sie besuchen. Und wenn Sie mal bei der Fortuna sind, ja, vielleicht kann man da auch Spaß wünschen, ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich bin ja sowohl Mitglied bei Fortuna Düsseldorf, wie auch bei der Düsseldorfer EG.
Ja, das ist doch ein wunderbares Schlusswort. Danke Ihnen für Ihre Zeit. Machen Sie es gut.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Das war das kurze Gespräch über die EU Sports Policy. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf euer Feedback dazu. Gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de oder über alle sozialen Netzwerke, in denen wir so aktiv sind. Freue mich sehr über Rückmeldungen zu diesem Thema. War ja doch mal ein etwas anderer Kurzpass als sonst. Ansonsten wünsche ich euch weiter eine gute Zeit. Der Rasenfunk bleibt paywall, Werbe und Sponsoren frei. Wir finanzieren uns allein über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubund auf rasenfunk.de/tribünengesprächfindetihr auch so das eine oder andere andere Gespräch oder die ein oder andere andere Sendung zu solchen sportpolitischen oder übergreifenden Themen. Da, wo der Sport in die Politik greift und umgekehrt. Ich bin gespannt, was dahingehend noch kommen wird. Jetzt erst mal wünsche ich euch noch eine gute Zeit. Bleibt gesund und bis bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk.